I'm sort of starting to hope very very
cautiously that American farmers are
realizing that Donald Trump is the
reason that a lot of these new struggles
they're experiencing are part of their
reality and hopefully they're going to
hold them accountable for that in 2020
particularly because a lot of those
Midwest states in which these farmers
were side were very close in 2016 and
could make the difference between Donald
Trump being reelected or not being
reelected as you may know the White
House has been running up these huge
deficits with their tax cut for the rich
they've also been running up deficits
with subsidies to farmers to make up for
the crushing consequences of Donald
Trump's tariffs and the White House has
now announced that they're going to add
an additional 16 billion dollars to help
out farmers but the bailout of the
farmers does not actually solve the
underlying issue which is that the
tariffs that Donald Trump has put in
place have decimated the markets in
which these farmers operates soybean
farmers are being destroyed in the US
China's going to Brazil for soybeans
instead of coming here that's great for
China it's great for Brazilian farmers
it's terrible for American farmers and
for our own economy since our farmers
have less money that they can then spend
within the United States when the wheat
farmers started to be destroyed as a
result of Trump's tariffs China started
going to Russian regions for wheat it's
fine for China
certainly welcomed by Russian farmers
it's not so great for the United States
so we're finally starting to hear from
farmers that they're recognizing that
this is a direct result of Donald
Trump's trade policy that this is the
trade war and remember Trump ran on he
understands trade better than anyone
he's going to fix trade and none of it
has happened the question then becomes
if they realize it the farmers that is
will they hold Trump accountable in 2020
I have no idea but I hope so but it's
important to understand that just
because you don't like Trump's trade
policy or recognize that it's been
hurting you it doesn't necessarily mean
you're going to vote for a Democrat if
you're a Midwestern Republican farmer
now there's also another winner from
this trade war and this is not being
discussed that much and I think it's
important
these tariffs are a handout to American
big farming or big agribusiness in that
as the small farmers struggle to make
ends meet they have much less of an
ability to weather unstable revenue than
do the big agribusiness companies a lot
of those small farmers will start to
think damn maybe I should get out of
this business I wonder if I could maybe
sell out altogether maybe some huge
agribusiness conglomerate will buy me
out at a significant discount because
I'm struggling so badly which has the
effect of further consolidating the food
production of the United States among
few very large factory farmers and
multinational agribusiness type
companies so make no mistake if you're a
farmer and you voted for Trump this is
what you voted for in the sense that
Trump promised it he pretended to have a
clue about tariffs and trade he clearly
convinced enough people that he has a
clue on that to get them to vote for him
and he did what he promised to do it's a
disaster and anyone who understood what
Trump was planning to do knew it would
be a disaster all along they did do it
to themselves those farmers but I still
feel for them I guess I see them as
adults who decide things for themselves
except they have a disease of sorts
called hyper-partisanship like in the
same way that you wouldn't get mad at
someone for being an alcoholic because
it's sort of like getting mad at someone
for being a diabetic uh we have all of
us to some degree have this partisanship
that blinds us in some way shape or form
you become addicted to political party
you become drunk off of disinformation
and political attack ads and talking
points and then you end up voting for
Donald Trump and destroying your own own
business by virtue of the policies that
you vote in but by voting for Donald
Trump in the first place and that's why
sadly many of these farmers are going to
vote for Donald Trump again because they
ain't votin for no Democrat [ __ ]
liberal they decided I guess that a
businessman with a track record of
bankruptcy of not paying vendors and
employing undocumented immigrants and
scamming people was the guy to lead them
forward and now this is what they get
but you know what I still want to help
them out and I'll be doing it at least
partially partially by working to remove
Donald Trump in 2020 even if a lot of
these farmers are going to vote for
their continued self-destruction by
voting to re-elect Donald Trump in 2020
and many of them sadly will hopefully
enough of them realize not only is this
trump's fault but i should vote for
someone else in november of 2020 that he
will lose some of those Midwestern
states that he won in 2016 way too early
to know but obviously we will eventually
figure that out today's program is
sponsored in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman if you've not already heard about
blankets it's amazing it's an app for
your phone tablet or web browser and
what they do is they take nonfiction
books popular nonfiction critically
acclaimed nonfiction they condense the
book into a fifteen minute audio book
you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin recent one
is a Robert Rice's new book the common
good also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink as comm slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n